PRESIDENT A MONTH AGO, JUST
POINTING OUT.
WHO CHECKS THE FACT-CHECKER
GUIDE?
JOINING US WITH REACTION,
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
BEFORE I GET TO THIS, I THINK
ONE OF YOUR FINEST MOMENTS IN
THE U.S. SENATE WAS DURING THE
KAVANAUGH HEARING AND YOU HAD
HAD ENOUGH.
NOW, YOU’VE GOT ALL THESE NEW
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
GOVERNOR CUOMO.
I DON’T KNOW THE TRUTH OF -- I
DON’T KNOW IF THESE THINGS ARE
TRUE.
I THOUGHT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
FRANKLY, FOR ONCE ACTUALLY
HANDLED THAT SITUATION WITH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH THE RIGHT WAY,
OKAY?
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
WE ARE GOING TO STOP, PAUSE, AND
INVESTIGATE.
AND THEY DID.
WE FOUND OUT A LOT OF LIES WERE
TOLD AND YOU HAD ENOUGH.
I DON’T KNOW THE CASE HERE.
I BELIEVE IN DUE PROCESS,
PERCEPTION OF INNOCENCE,
SENATOR .
>> WELL, NUMBER ONE, THE IDEA
THAT CUOMO WOULD APPOINT HIS OWN
INVESTIGATOR TELLS YOU A LOT
ABOUT HIS MIND-SET.
SO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW
PILING ON ANDREW CUOMO BECAUSE
HE’S MADE A LOT OF ENEMIES ALONG
THE WAY, BUT YOU’VE BEEN
CONSISTENT AND I’VE BEEN
CONSISTENT.
WE ALLOWED DR. FORD TO BE HEARD.
IF THERE WERE FIVE ACCUSATIONS
AGAINST JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, THREE
WERE LITERALLY MADE UP AND WHEN
IT COMES TO DR. FORD, I THINK
SOMETHING HAPPENED TO HER, BUT I
DON’T THINK BRETT KAVANAUGH HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT AT ALL
I’M ASKING MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES WHO BELIEVED EVERY
WORD DR. FORD SAID, EVEN BEFORE
JUDGE KAVANAUGH SPOKE, AND WE
DID AN INVESTIGATION, YOU’RE NOW
GIVING CUOMO A COMPLETE PASS.
SCHUMER WENT ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE DAY IN AND DAY OUT
ACCUSING ALL OF US REPUBLICANS
OF SUPPORTING SEXUAL ASSAULT.
HAVE YOU HEARD HIM SAY ONE WORD
ABOUT THIS?
SO THE DOUBLE STANDARD IS PRETTY
OBVIOUS, BUT THE ONE THING THAT
I CAN’T EXPLAIN TO YOU, I
COULDN’T WALK 3 FEET DURING THE
KAVANAUGH HEARING WITHOUT SOME
REPORTER STICKING A MICROPHONE
IN MY FACE, WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THE NEW ACCUSATION?
AND THE IDEA THAT KAVANAUGH WAS
GUILTY WAS PERVASIVE.
THE ACCUSATION WAS SELF PROVING.
IF I HAVEN’T HAD ONE PERSON
ASKED ME ABOUT THE ACCUSATION
AGAINST GOVERNOR CUOMO FROM THE
MEDIA, NOT ONE.
>> Sean: SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS
MADE BY TARA READE AND ANOTHER
WOMAN OUT IN NEVADA.
NOW DO WE GO BACK AND TAKE THOSE
ALLEGATIONS SERIOUSLY?
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU HAD A WHOLE
I BELIEVE HER CAUCUS AND THE
RISK OF PEOPLE, I WILL SCROLL
AGAIN, THAT ARE SILENT NOW THAT
WERE SO VOCAL THEN IS PRETTY
DARN LONG, SENATOR .
>> WELL, HERE’S WHAT I WOULD
TELL MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES TO
DO.
FOLLOW THE REPUBLICAN MODEL.
WE HAD A REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR
THE SUPREME COURT BE ACCUSED OF
SOMETHING THE DAY BEFORE WE
VOTED.
THE MOMENT BEFORE WE VOTED.
WE COULD HAVE GONE AHEAD SAYING
THIS WAS TOO LATE, YOU SAT ON
IT, YOU DIDN’T TELL US, THIS IS
NOT FAIR.
WE STOPPED THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
WE HAD DAYS AND WEEKS OF
HEARINGS, WE HAD ANOTHER FBI
INVESTIGATION, WE TOOK IT
SERIOUSLY AND WHAT SHOULD YOU DO
AS DEMOCRATS REGARDING CUOMO?
DO EXACTLY WHAT REPUBLICANS DID.
CALL FOR AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION, TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, LET ME
MOVE ON, WE WILL KEEP SCROLLING
AND AIMS BECAUSE IT’S PRETTY
LONG, SO PEOPLE CAN GET THE FULL
PICTURE.
THE PRESIDENT’S SPEECH AT CPAC,
NO THIRD PARTY,
AMERICA-FIRST AGENDA, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGENDA.
MITCH McCONNELL, TO HIS CREDIT
CREDIT, SAID YEAH, I VOTE FOR
HIM AS THE NOMINEE.
DISAGREEMENTS AT TIMES,
RONALD REAGAN SAID WE AGREE 80%
OF THE TIME, YOU’RE NOT MY
ENEMY.
IS HE RIGHT?
>> YEAH, REAGAN WAS RIGHT AND I
JUST TALKED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO AND I
SAID LISTEN, IT’S NOT NECESSARY
FOR EVERYBODY TO LIKE EACH
OTHER.
I ACTUALLY LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE’S BEEN VERY NICE TO ME.
HE’S ALLOWED ME TO BE IN HIS
WORLD, HE ALLOWS ME TO GIVE MY
TWO CENTS WORTH ABOUT DIFFERENT
ISSUES WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT.
THIS IS HIS PARTY.
IF YOU DON’T GET THAT, YOU
MISSED A LOT AT CPAC.
DONALD TRUMP HAS THE NOMINATION
RIGHT NOW AND NOBODY CAN TAKE IT
AWAY FROM HIM IF HE WANTS TO
RUN.
AND I THINK HE’S GOT A GOOD
CHANCE OF GETTING REELECTED
AGAIN BASED ON WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING TO THE
COUNTRY.
BUT WHAT I WOULD TELL
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE REAL TEST
FOR YOU AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS 2022.
LET’S MAKE SURE WE HAVE OUR BEST
CANDIDATES ON THE FIELD, LET’S
DON’T HAVE PRIMARIES OF PEOPLE
WHO THINK GOOD REPUBLICAN
CONSERVATIVES, LET’S UNITE, AND
IF WE WILL FOLLOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LEAD THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE UNITED
REPUBLICAN PARTY, WE ARE GOING
TO PUT OUR BEST TEAM ON THE
FIELD IN 2022, THAT SETS THE
STAGE FOR A 2024 COME BACK.
WE’VE GOT A LOT OF TALENTED
PEOPLE IN THE PARTY, SEAN.
DID YOU FIND ONE PERSON AT CPAC
CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP?
I THOUGHT IT WAS AMAZING THAT
YOU HAD SO MANY PEOPLE WANTING
TO BE PRESIDENT ON OUR SIDE BUT
NOT ONE PERSON WOULD SAY
ANYTHING BAD ABOUT HIM.
THAT TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT THE
STRENGTH OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: WILL YOU HELP ME
DRAFT HERSCHEL WALKER TO RUN FOR
SENATE DONNA GEORGIA?